who wants to play body spotty's bodies  guys i get so stressed out every time we  play this someone always ends up crying  [Laughter]  so how do you play  if you draw the piece of paper that has  the x on it you are the murderer  everyone else has to avoid being killed  what is that  say next you want one yeah  what is happening  our friend is dead so if you could just  like not escalate the situation that i'm  not escalating you're holding the knife  and you're moving your hands while you  talk  that would be so [ __ ] obvious if i  were the killer david moore  you're always gaslighting me  you [ __ ] trigger me you are so toxic  relax relax you're silencing me  did you just [ __ ] shoot me i can't  believe you're making this about you  [Music]  what are you the features that you're  bringing well i just look like i [ __ ]  you know what i mean  i look like i [ __ ]  and that's the vibe i like to put out  there yeah  [Music]  you